and when you look at the people around
you and you look at how people respond
to you you're constantly battling
yourself and it is self
um and and for me I had to heal first I
had to First figure out what was the
trauma yeah where's the problem
um and with that you don't even know
where to begin because you don't know
what the problem is and then you have to
Soul search you have to look who you've
got around you you then have to look at
your parents
um how you grew up your school days
um and all of that you have to calculate
and sometimes you are the problem
sometimes the way that you've behaved is
a problem however the way that you've
behaved isn't necessarily because you've
wanted to be that way but you was trying
to be something that you was not and